欢迎收看最佛心幽默的残经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好 8月快要过完了
今天星期五
我们创下了一个反弹后的新高
而且今天的量能也有微微放大到一兆左右
整个8月截至目前为止
已经创下了外资最大的单月买超纪录
外资好像确确实实的回头了
而景气灯号也开出了第八颗的红灯
好走到这里
大家观察今天盘面上会发现
不止一些领头羊在长之外
今天长得倒有蛮多事
大家心里面很喜爱
但是这段时间反弹不见得很多的
例如说像金居金像店
金元店等等的
甚至像被动元件的国具性仓店
所以大家的心里面都会很希望
是不是这些比较落后的
但是以前大家好喜欢的股票
能够接棒继续往上攻
那这一波会这么的强
我想挥打真的功不可没
真的把魔咒给破除了
连续实际
这个所谓财报后的下跌
在昨天晚上彻底颠覆
大涨了8个多个百分点
好那气势到下个礼拜
能不能延续
还是会出现转折
我想这个真的非常重要
所以我们来欢迎今天的三位来宾
好第一位是盈利投资的
中国中总
好中大胆
一定要提醒大家
虽然今天创下了反弹高
但是我们还有一件事情
大家都忘了吗
全球央行年会要开了
所以在这个部分
利率恐怕还是盘面上
我们一定要关注的一件事情
会不会带来一些些的压力
但是今天盘面上
像被动元件这种
比较落后反弹的
谈起来了
它到底能不能满血复活
关键就在于
里面有成分股是MSCI
这是要调整的时候
要新增的
中大大很关注这件事
所以会告诉大家
这一次MACI的换股里面
独家帮您看
后续延续性强的好股票
已经扫描出来了
好 第二位是我们的
国家级基金操盘手
黄丰凯 凯哥
凯哥也要讲
虽然回答的财报
较出好成绩
可是麦威尔的财报
大家却有点压力了
到底在跌什么
可是麦威尔跌我们的CPU
没有跌
我们的发哥拉尾盘
这些都有原因
再来我们看投信雖然外資大買但投信這一波的方向比較不明朗喔被投信丟掉的例如像探针系列或者像之前大家喜欢的金像电联电有没有可能捡回来呢
另外今天新发生一件事
星星我们的载版龙头
被捡掉搜索了
投信今天是跑不掉的
下个礼拜一到底该如何处置
凯哥会告诉您他的方案
好第三位呢
是我们的当冲破断双刀流高献荣
好 谢龙也在关注外资一直买
单月的历史买超新高
真没想到前七个月
把我们卖得乱七八糟
所以谢龙今天也是独家帮您看了
外资持续买超
而且今年的营收年增率
超过35个百分点的有底气
外资加持的是哪些
另外大户也在持续布局
布局电力股
为何如此不离不弃
等一下告诉您
他心灵中的好表弟
好 首先有请总总
好 总总
這個禮拜五是創下了反彈新高
但是你也會提醒大家
我們的央行年會
全球央行年會還沒開
等一下要怎麼關注
被動國際現倉電已經回血了
能不能繼續呢
MSCI的換股大戲
是您一向最關注的
是沒錯
那當然我想這幾天
大家市場上最關注的重點
就是全球央行年會最深厚
那我們包括我們看過去
歷年來的最深厚開完之後
這個標準500
標普500的部分
大家可以看到
包括從葉倫到豹爾的時代來看
演說了當天大概是上
其實這邊的上漲機率都高
就七成以上 看起來是很高
但是今年面臨到通膨高於目標
而且美債殖利率最近的攀升
以及政府的債務膨脹的一些壓力
市場未必會再給出現一個正面的反應
那尤其這個費德
如果讓這個通膨回落到2%
政策還不明朗
不過我個人認為說
滑雪應該不會有激烈的言論
不過要注意一下是日本升息機率
可能會比較高
因為之前包括高市
有陳迪提到過
可能會在9月的部分
日圓可能會做升息
那我們再回頭再來看一下
全球股市的部分
稻穹指數在這一波當中
我們之前一提到
它一直沿著這條月線在走
但是先前最強是稻穹指數
創新高之後拉回
但是昨天出現一個大量
大量又沒有上漲
換句話說表示說
這個走勢還不是很穩定
是 比較黏一點
那台積電呢
在輝達的激烈情況之下
那這邊來講就是問到之前提到過一個下降的壓力線位置那當然這两天就是观察它这个部分的下降的趋势能不能突破如果没有突破
那相对来讲
它可能还是进行一个
峡谱区间的盘整的部分
我想这个是有关于
这个补市的部分
至于再回头来看台股
台股呢
这礼拜量说价涨
这边量这样子只有4.07兆
那今天来看的话
量是有稍微到一兆多
不过一兆多呢
开始又面临到一个问题
上次我提到过
每次达到1.1兆
就是开始面临到一个叫做
你丢我检的
或者筹码的换手的动作
上次呢
因为会来到4万6千多
是因为双I效应
就上次我提到过
这个升息降趋势
CPI
还有一个CPI
那这次呢
有机会又来到
是因为亏打的效应
那今天呢
刚好突破一兆多
不过各位也不要忘记
今天一兆多
但是今天有一个副台指结算
如果没有副台指结算
可能要一兆
可能有点连想还更
换句话说
这两天你要继续观察
这个量是不是能够在一兆以上
为什么
因为要把先前
上市在这个月中的时候
这部分的1.1兆
要顺便要做一个换手的成功
才能够往上推
所以我个人认为说
这个46,500点是附近不追高
但是拉回来是
是可以做一个买进的动作
那我个人认为说
还是会进行一个区间整理
前坡这边46350附近
你还是把手中指骨降低
极短线
我想极短线就是
大概45000这附近月线这边
对
那8月份今天虽然
还有一天的交易日
不过8月份确定应该是量缩价涨
因为上个月有21兆
这个月只有17兆多
所以这坡应该是
立为一个跌生反弹的格局
需要再反复的整理动作
再就是要看一下OTC的部分
OTC在这波当中
已经来到这个季线
还有几线位置
上次也是在这边踩到压力
我觉得今天要去注意一下
OTC的融资的部分
如果你刻意注意一下
台湾的融资
尤其是在上柜的部分
更明显
你会发现上面的走势图
跟融资走势图
是一本一模一样
所以换句话说
你看从这个8月初到现在
这个走势基本上就一模一样
换句话说
如果這邊的融資有再增加
相對這個大盤
挑戰這個季限壓力就非常高相反如果是說到這個季限這邊融資有出現減少或是甚至再往下降一些那可能這部分力道可能就是會稍微弱一點
我想這個部分是要注意一下
今天晚上公布的這融資的變化
好 所以希望融資反而增加
願意增加買盤
聰明融資 沒錯
今天這個被動元件
在這個輝達的效應
也幾率少有一些
現前沒漲到
因為我們知道
之前都先漲CPU
還有其他這些相關的載版
或等等的
但是一直漲不起來的被動元件
因為籌碼因素
所以今天可以看到
何生堂今天出現漲停板
那其他還有包括華新科
還有國具
當然最主要市場關心的是
國具的部分
還有日電貿 信倉店這邊
那我抓兩家公司
給大家做參考
所以我個人認為說
被動元件是未來是可以
稍微去特別再注意
除了它的這次的漲幅
乖離不是很高以外
下禮拜MSCI會把核生堂
納進去 核生堂
那再來就是被動元件
目前的一線長
它相對位階是在高
像國際是還在剛好從低檔起來
相對已經到了上次的位置區
更何況這邊有大量位置
換句話說
如果這波的一線長要往上攻
核生堂絕對是下禮拜
要關注的重點
因為它是被納入MSCI的新承諾股
如果被納入MSCI新承諾股
還不會帶動其他的整個族群的話
那這個族群就可能要
就要辛苦一點
是 領某陽
再來另外一個就是日電報
那日電報我為什麼抓這家公司
是可以做參考是
因為這個是屬於攻擊組
這個是防守組
那今年來講
我大概算一算明年的股利
應該有機會配到9塊
殖利率5%
換句話說這個相對低
哇 它談不太動
譬如說穩健行的人
如果在這個位置
你明年殖利率可能就5%左右
所以是攻守
我認為說都已經在做一個
具備等機會了
好
那這是下禮拜MECI要生效的公司
今天怎麼漲跌那麼劇烈
因為CPU的部分
我今天沒有特別會提到
是因為這一波先漲多的
先拉回
為什麼 你們會發現
今天跌的都比較多
就是像之前本益比的
像CPU的有沒有
有些比較大的
都是今天反而下跌
今天反而是本益比比較合理的
坦白講這邊基本上本益比都算高的
都是四五十以上
所以你會發現到今天的京居
和珊黨他們的本益比都50倍
比今年目前佔顧了本益比來看
其他來講像藍郡國際也是一樣
所以我發現
因為靠近的時候他本來是買這個
像今天肩點也漲了
所以這個65%
對
那是因為聯合再生是9%
不過是靠業外
本業還是虧損的
那當然還有一些
聯合金屬創
配爾生衣創
這因為版面實在放不下
這個創
創新版
好
那這時候會放那個是因為
各位看一下
這上個月
上一次
5月29號
MCI的成長
因為每季都會幫大家做追蹤
MCI納入成分股
真的有沒有值得去追蹤
確實有
他大概上次大概新納入的一些
新的成分股
大概有將近八檔到九檔
那裡面順德創新高
這邊又差了起來
最標準厲害 台虹
放在這邊 不怎麼樣子
到最後面竟然漲一倍
PTFE太亮
一漲一倍
所以換句話說
哪一檔會被下次被向中
會做一個所謂任陽股
特別做賬股
那就大家去再隨時追蹤
當然下次我也再幫大家做追蹤
對 好
那今天我會講兩家公司
一家是經驅
還有一家是非電的部分
首先我們看電子的經驅
坦白講電子這個本益比50倍
不是我會喜歡 喜歡看的
不過在裡面看下去
本益比合理的
我覺得看得比較順眼的
就真的只有經驅
高階同伯
真的是不容易就是它
因為什麼
首先看它營業的部分
確實每個月的營業
YiY將近有四五成
算是一個成長型的
那前七個月將近有45%左右
那其實上Tata之前研發一些相關的
這個算是高頻高速的超低速照度的
這些銅箔
對整個目前AI的發展來講
它算是很重要的部分
再來就是重點是各位看到
它的營業率成長
現在到上半年的話將近有25%
比之前的18% 16%
坦白講有擴大的部分
上半年EPS是4.2
如果按照這樣的話
市場上預估
今天EPS保守應該有10%
一個資本額
那盈獄率我剛才提到創新高
所以看起來的話
它目前來講應該是有機會
會在下一次季度當中被
被特別關照
那股利率的部分大概不高
因為這個算是高價股成長股
那我們來看一下
它的股價走勢
好 滿意想這篇的股價走勢
它之前最高來到754.55
那這一波當中一口氣漲很多
沒有上車的反而在這波當中下來打回原點了你會發現一個現況這邊都沒有什麼套牢區搶短的沒有什麼搶短換句話說為什麼我們說這邊你可以留意是因為
在這波過程當中
就線來看
所有的均線都在下面
換句話說
近一年 近半年 近一季
大家的成本都一樣
而這個反彈過程當中
最主要是在這波當中
只有這邊量比較大
還有這邊比較大
但是你現在目前的位置
还有一点点的距离
所以这边的强短空间
套牢的强
这个所谓的强
强这个短线的人比较少
我个人觉得这部分应该是有机会
如果未来有拉肥的话
我想这边有机会呈现一个
超级黄金的交叉点部分
所以我想这个部分是可以
可以丢于今天已经过了季线的位置
金居我们算常送暖的
这是电子的部分
那非电的部分呢
就来讲一个叫雷虎
也要送暖了
这个条例预算通过
怎麼今天可以壓壓的一片
因為電子有一部分
我抓一個飛電
那為什麼放這無人機
無人機今天看起來預算通過
怎麼今天看起來
好像開高總定不開心
我們先講一下它的部分
通過無人機的預算
基本上就是產業成長
就是趨勢又更確立
那營業的部分
現在目前大概是
沒有怎麼特別成長
因為還欠這個預算通過
但是整體看起來
目前已經有改善
為什麼
它的營業率的部分
負得0.26%
慢慢好一點
不過第二屆營業率
已經有0.1%
那下個月9月15號
國際塑膠橡膠的工業長
在9月15號登場
漢翔跟雷虎
會去被邀請分享
這個前瞻的技術
相關的這些的零件的
這個應用的部分
重點是非獨立董鞋持股
6月份
上次我也來特別提到過
650張
然後6月份是售169.5%
那存貨已經比上次第一季來的低
上次是25%
現在已經降到23%左右
那下一次呢
下個禮拜我為什麼說
可以看特別看這個無人機的部分
因為下個禮拜9月3號
有一家新公司掛牌
叫3718中光電投控
中光電投控
原來就叫做中光電
從一天一股換一股
所以呢下個禮拜
你會想說奇怪
最近人家買5371
怎麼中光電不見
因為現在現在就要換股當中
下禮拜9月3號
所以我想下禮拜
如果針光店要剛掛牌的話會不會有所謂的一些所謂的慶祝效應我不知道但是如果看起来的话这个部分可以自己值得观察毕竟刚换完之后
然后马上就那个不好
还蛮奇怪的
当然我们先来看
刚刚我提到过
六月份的非独冚肩持股增加
是在这个位置
那收盖就在最为要
换句话说你现在位置也
坦白讲
你觉得位阶较高还较低
叫位阶较低
因为九月份呢
这次来讲的话
行政院要把这个部分送到总统府
总统府要做一个要看完之后
然后再去交给行政院再做附属
所以我想9月份应该这个预算
无人间预算应该还是市场上
会关注的重点之一的部分
因为它走成一座山对不对
现在在整理
所以总总是觉得后续来说
其实预算通过对军工股整体还是有利的
我个人觉得说你不要去看这个
什么什么这个所谓的成交量问题
因为没过的话
也是差不多这
有过至少表示未来这个比
是越来越会大
只是说早晚的问题
如果今天股价是在这位间
那你可能就要考虑到这问题
如果位间是在这里
那我个人就觉得
这部分的可能或许
要把先前这边的筹码
稍微做一个适当换手整理
除非你就换一个角度
我常常讲
无卵机预算通过
它以后股价是这样跌
那就很奇怪
顶多就是这样子
另外一种就是这样子
我想这个部分应该
这个跟这个的可能性比较高
这个部分应该是比较小一些
好 准备非常谢谢钟总
好 谢谢赵华
好 钟总提到
这个礼拜是亮缩往上走
那我们不要忽略了
全球央行年会
可能会公布的一些利率的决策走向
当然华许是比较揭末派的
那我们就且战且走
因为同盘面上
以个股来说
有很多还在比较相对低档
被动元件往上攻
要来看合生堂了
因为合生堂有被纳入MSCI的新选股
每一季总总都会很在意这个选股
因为他们的延续性后来证明都是好的
因此今天也从最新的MSSI要换股里面
挑出两档一档电子一档飞电
给您做选股的参考哦
好广告回来凯哥要上场了
那凯哥也要讲
今天盘面上虽然CP有点压力
但似乎不太受到Mineware的影响
下一步该怎么走
另外的大戏在投信的身上哦
今天有很多的股票是之前投信爱过的
现在手上持股低的会不会回补
还有就是星星啊
被搜索了
手上有载版的朋友好紧张
等一下来帮您做全面解惑凱哥今天很忙不過今天的話題
其實跟投信很有關係
例如CPO
這一波投信是有慢慢加碼的
那今天盤面上
有很多漲的股票是
之前投信愛過
但也丟掉了
例如誰呢
例如剛剛講到的
像金像電 金元電 聯電
甚至旺系這樣的公司
還有就是今天
投信高持股的栽班股
星星電子被搜索
到底會對載版三雄或是四雄
造成什麼樣的壓力
下個禮拜一我們該怎麼辦呢
這邊就要來請教凱哥了
因為今天星星被搜索
發現投信沒跑掉
那會不會禮拜一來補跑呢
我們先一個一個看
麥威爾昨天的財報
結果對於前景的預期
似乎大家不買單
不過今天我們的CPU状況還行啦
那投信之前錯殺的
像聯電金像電會回補嗎
探偵會回補嗎
那星星電子怎麼辦
我刚刚转那边啊
我看到这个
我想说怎么写一个
减碳针坏
为什么坏
因为减碳其实是
这件事情的杀手
我感觉有人利用减掉
在做杀手
马贝尔昨天的财报啊
其实没有讲不好
可是它是跌的
我们可以看到它的重点
就是其实它昨天的
主要会跌的原因就在于
它的营收展望其实没有很好
我们也很好
虽然上调15亿美元
其实远远的低于市场的预期
因为市场觉得它跟这个Google
有进行一个投资的一个合作
理论上应该是要大幅的提升
在这个ESIC的部分
在提升ESIC的部分
但昨天的营收它调高的理由
主要是来自于这个光学的部分
就是CPO
所以今天其实你看
大部分的细光值
其实都没有什么大跌
都没有什么大跌
联均还涨停
对啊
那我们来看联雅
雷雅其實這兩天
就在進行一個休息
進行一個休息
但是其實外資還是不離不棄
外資還是不離不棄
好 我覺得凱哥這邊講一句
蠻厲害的
7月24號講的
投信賣了3500多張
今天開始大買
我覺得這地方要往上回走了
這一走走了快九成
是 所以這是給我的獎狀
我們在看CPU確實是
但投信回買是真的
對 因為我們講過嘛
第三季隨著零化音的基板
零化硬的基板
開始產能開始出來了
其實大家的業績都會開始上來
所以你看不是聯亞漲
其實像全新也漲
前行也涨
那大家比较关注的是
Mavio讲的这么差
那股价是下跌的
可是跟他关系最紧密的是
滑星光
他也没有什么跌啊
你看投薪是不是
最近是不是积极的在买
很红场
对啊
因为他就是有数字嘛
确实他的EP的数字
确实是漂亮的
漂亮的
那你看买卖超的部分
基本上是18000多张
对7000多张
但是形态上来看
他确实这边
还有一点点的压力
還有一點點壓力
剛好碰到
對 還有一點壓力
但是其實以日線來看
其實就已經在創新高了
但是周的角度
其實還有一點點
需要繼續的努力
繼續努力
但是跟Maveo
基本上沒有什麼太大影響
Maveo有什麼太大影響
CPU是投信愛的
這邊就是投信
對 猶豫的
投信之前殺過的
這個總統講的國劇
是 聯電
日月光頭控
台達 核生堂
金像電
後面的你比較喜歡
怎麼投信殺的
都沒有殺下去 還拉起來
那就表示投信是殺錯
那我們來看一下
其中比較特殊的就是聯電
這真的很多人關心
對 因為我剛才講過
就是聯電它有一個什麼
細電容的部分
我那時候就直接講了
就是它有細電容
雖然那時候大家都在講立即電
我說它有點被殺的有點冤枉
那今天外資就回來買
這個真的很猛
外資回來買了8萬多張
今天投信就稍微買得比較少
所以就拉上來
沒有買還賣
拉上來
但是你看喔
它這一根的量其實蠻大根的喔
是
這根的量
其實遠遠超過這一根喔
所以看起來這裡
震盪完之後還會再往上走
是
還會再往上走
那如果以州的形態來講
它也還只是一個反彈
是
還沒有構成所謂的直接的V轉
還沒有構成
為什麼
因為這邊確實張數差太多了
買賣超的張數
18萬張對56萬張
是
對 所以我覺得它
只是讓它稍微怎麼樣
深淵
但是還沒有到說
可以讓他直接坐到電上
直接當官的位置
是
接著看金像電
金像電
基本上我們之前也有來賓
不離不棄
金像鏈
本節目對金像鏈確實不離不棄
是
他業績不錯
你看今天投信就開始回來買了
投信開始認錯
就是投信開始會回來買
之前他殺的股票
今天土洋同賣
對
他會回來買他之前殺的股票因為其實這些股票不是他不愛可是他不愛而是我那時候講過他們氣棄小就大有沒有我說他們棄小的電子股買大的買大的所以你看他現在就開始回來買
形態上來講
他目前的大量高在這裡
我就突破了
而且你看從州的角度來看
就更明顯了
州的部分也是突破大量高
所以看起來
他就持續往上漲
接下來看的是國劇
接下來看的是國聚
國聚今天雖然投信還在賣
土洋同賣
國聚投信還在賣
好辛苦
但是因為今天有指標股往上拉
剛剛我們總統有講
今天像和聲堂 信商店都拉起來了
對不對 小弟都拉起來了
大哥再怎麼艱困
也要想辦法醒過來
基本上也不用太難過
你看這也很離譜
賣了12萬張 只買了2萬多張
所以他還在泥澡中慢慢要爬起來
我看到有人在問說
會不會回到一千
先不要想一千啦
先反攻再說啦
對 因為我覺得
九月是他們一個反攻的契機
反攻的契機
再來就是我剛剛講
這個檢調真壞
今天的一點多
兩個副總一個會計被帶回
傳出的訊息
所以他是沙尾盤
從這邊跳水
而且投信來不及走
因為一點多
大部分同志經理人
不是在休息就是在吃飯
這是你在投信的心得嗎
因為投信他們大部分是開盤前單
對啦
他不會在盤中突然下單
盤中突然下單是有緊急的事情
像這個確實是有符合
要緊急下單
可是因為他們在外面
所以還不急回來
再來就是因為他傳出的事情
大家第一想法就是
他不是優等生嗎
對啊 資優生
對啊 他是優等生
會有什麼大事呢
但是你看他今天
下午很多內幕就跑出來了
但我覺得很奇怪
就是現在還在檢調的調查當中
檢調不公開
為什麼會有這些東西出來
好 有聽到很多說法嗎
第一個當然大家會
立刻想到內線交易
第二個說人家產品什麼洗產地
我想凱哥都看完了
你覺得可能性呢
我覺得我要替他講一句話
什麼
就是第一個是
星星本身他也有大陸廠
對
那洗什麼產地呢
那星星大陸做的不能嗎
是可以
唯一的可能就是
他星星大陸的產地出來
它是不是這個材料上面
是寫Made in China
還是直接就打Made in Taiwan我覺得這個可能有一點點的瑕疵但是其實公司下午就有發聞稿了他說對業績 對財務沒有影響公司發的新聞稿是說
目前一切營運正常
對 那他會這樣子寫
我覺得比較大的問題會出現在投信
因為我剛剛講的
他是優等生
你這樣被寫出來表示什麼
表示你的內控有問題
他昨天才創歷史新稿
今天也有創喔
對 表示你的內控有問題
那问题造成投信会怎样
会不敢再买它啦
至少会不敢再买
但是对整个ABF族群
我个人觉得没有影响
真的喔
因为现在已经有人说
会不会景硕也会被插
会不会南电也被插
不是啊
因为景硕 新兴 南电
他们在大陆多多厂啊
虽然他们大陆厂多的东西
你说他们就是起产地
不会太夸张了吧
是
而且你要知道
这么高阶的ABF
目前大陆是没有能力做得出来的
你就想這件事情就懂了
所以我覺得
講習慣地這裡有點在
刻意的要模糊焦點
模糊焦點
然後再來今天又傳出什麼
內線交易 對
因為這個台灣史上還蠻多的
然後又講說
它涉及什麼農工農的法規
是 對
所以我覺得它有點怪
有點怪
但是我個人就覺得
基本上投信會是比較大的問題
因為投信買很多了
所以投信只要稍微減碼
就會讓它下來
好 我們來看一下
今天的形態
距离这个低点
有一点点的危险
因为今天盘中有稍微拉起来
可是大家没有想到的是
这个新闻故意做很大
它跟一般的检调搜索不太一样
我个人觉得
如果是个人一般检调搜索
如果是搜索主力
不搜索公司
那可能就是一天的反应
可是它是搜索公司
而且还带走了
人家民副总
我觉得这影响就会比较大一点
而且我觉得涉及的
就是我刚刚讲公司治理
公司治理的问题
所以我觉得可能
ABF不会大跌
但是星星跑不掉
在节难逃
那手上有的朋友
那我们来看一下
怎么办
我觉得他可能会先跌到这里
哪里
哇塞不得了
大概在900到1000的附近
也就是说会跌到两三根
所以我觉得礼拜一有
还是要先减码一点
虽然外资还在买
对
外资还在买
对 越阶尾盘还勾起来对 但我觉得礼拜一跌一定是难免的而且其实公司在第一時間也很難去解釋得非常的清楚因為畢竟它不是只帶走一名會計
而是帶走兩名副總
那你說這中間會不會查查查
查出來什麼內線交易
這就很難講
因為有些公司是不能查
進不起查
因為這個內線的事情其實是
比較容易被查到的
是 那大家要转站景硕或南店吗
我个人觉得
因为大家之前都觉得
景硕是拿最佳进步奖
是
就是它就是60分
对
然后呢
这个欣欣呢
是90分
是
对
那一个90分一个60分
那现在这90分的不能买
你就可能只能回来买60分
是
因为投信最近确实也开始在青睐景硕
没错
对
那你刚好就让它一个理由
就说
那我就把景硕再加满
是
再加满
这是有可能的
有可能的
接着没来讲说
在这波行情里面
其实台股莫名其妙
已经有这么多的股票
都在五千块以上
五千还不是一千
五千块以上
五千
这台股史上难见的一个局面
对
在那么多五千的公司里面
居然有一个族群
有三家
三家公司
对
三家
这不是一个集团
是族群
是一个族群
族群长成一个五千族群
族群其實不太容易
所以我們今天就來看一下
那這個立基裡面其實我們大致來看
這個旺系隱威跟這個宏鏡
他們其實在碳針裡面可以這樣一分為二
這是前段 這是後段
這是在整個晶圓還沒有上線之前先做的檢測
股價來講看起來它有點委屈
但是如果就目前股价的位置
它跟它比较有搞头
比较有机会
我们等一下来讲一下
这是红镜
因为红镜跟建策
是同样的东西
也就是建策如果好
理论上红镜就要跟着好
建策最近很好
对 最近建策很好
建策很好
为什么红镜没有很好
好我们来看
红镜的大量的位置在这里
嗯
當然會在這裡
所以它已經在大量的下緣之上
是
所以它只差
這裡沒有站上而已
所以它是很有機會的
在這邊整理完之後怎麼樣
就會開始往上走
因為你想說
金冊已經往上走了
都在反映第四季到明年
它應該也要往上走
接著是日線來看
日線的大量在這裡
它也是站上的
只是離日的大量高
有一段距離
投信在賣
可是外資在賣
外資在賣
而且你看
買賣超其實是
買方略大於賣方
所以我覺得
鴻鏡還有機會再上一層樓
而且現在這個位置
離它的新高
還有一段距離
我覺得這個是不錯的
接下來看到旺系
旺系最近就比較慘
因為最近投信拼命賣
拼命賣
我們之前講過
它的第二間第三季
有一點錯字
所以市場有點不認同
周縣它有點壓力
為什麼
因為這一根的大量D在這裡
對
大量D在這裡
所以你看
它要站上這裡
整理完之後再往上
但是你可以看到
投信在賣
可是外資怎樣
已經開始回來賣
開始回來買了
那因為它就是很多的
BTF都有
所以我覺得要殺
就是大家一起跟著殺
但是只要這個多空力道
開始扭轉之後
他們就會覺得說
我賣錯了 我就不賣了
他就會開始往上爬
所以我覺得有點忘記是被挫殺
也是可以留意
所謂的被挫殺當然就是賣了之後
股價繼續往上
就只能說是被挫殺了
好 那現在的話
投信當然目前看來是把它賣下去了
能不能夠指穩讓投信買回來
就值得觀察
那因為現在千金股
5塊錢一跳改成1塊錢一跳了嘛
以後零股呢
12月7號開始也要從9點
對不對 就可以交易了
所以其實對於這種5千塊
大家不要壓力那麼大
都可以試試看
對 我覺得他可以看
你就是看
輝達其實對明年展望是很樂觀的
明年是70%的增長
對
70%的增長
對他而言就是大補完嘛
對 所以我覺得他還是會過高的
是 好啊
這麼有信心
非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝趙華
好 聽凱哥分享
真的覺得台股市場很有趣喔
麦威爾他其實對光通是按讚的
反而是ethic晶片這邊
有點讓人家覺得猶豫了
導致我們的發哥前一陣子
有點被誤殺下來的
現在看來聞啦
但是星星電子到底該怎麼辦
剛剛凱哥也提到了
投信是高持股
不一定會大賣
但是有可能會先不敢碰
這個事情我們要有認知
手上如果真的有很多的朋友
恐怕還是要稍微解碼做一下因應
我們近代後續到底調查的結果是如何但是有一些投信之嫌賣啊卖呀结果已经卖不下去的股票非常有机会回补也许也可以把资金稍微分散到一些这样的公司
会更为妥当
好 广告回来 现隆要上场啦
那现隆也要跟我们分享
大户现在在做什么
其实大户对电力真的叫不离不弃
而这些股价还慢慢变高
还有就是外资
单月最大的买超出现在8月
如果搭配外资买超
营收又是大幅成長的
那也是相當穩健
好 景希燈號
已經連續開出了8顆紅燈
史上的最高紀錄是9顆
這一次能不能創紀錄
還有外資在8月大買
上半年把我們砍爛掉了
現在大喊買
那能不能一直買到年底呢
這邊來請教憲榮
好 8顆紅燈當然往好處想
好熱喔 對不對
算数想就是史上也才9颗
那到底要破纪录吗
还是有什么问题
再来的话
外资已经在8月买了3709亿
还有下礼拜一
所以现在是一个
单月史高的状况下
外资买 营收又非常强
以及你还顺便看了一下
大户在做什么
好的 那第一个
先来看景气灯号的部分
现在公布出来
7月份连续8个红灯
而且这8个红灯不是说
看到41高点之后就往下掉了
目前都一直還維持在高峰
持續的熱絡之中
那當然最大的動力
就是來自於AI的供應鏈
持續的一個發展
所以目前來看
這個動能還在持續當中
尤其下半年會打的
Vera Rubin 以及GP300 亮彩
都還是有機會這地方繼續走高
挑戰2021年的
連久紅甚至超越
我覺得機率是滿高的
要創新紀錄
對 那當然如果說景氣持續熱絡
我們看到最近這外資
終於開始回頭之後
台幣的部分第一個先反應
最近已經從之前
一路的邊邊邊邊
扁到32.528之後
最近一口氣升回到31.57
升了快一塊錢的幅度了
那技術面現在是已經往下是升值
升破了這個地方
月線跟季線大觀之外
7月份你看到這一根升下來
它也過了7月份的一個低點了
所以這個結構上
台幣的確目前已經有
這回來的跡象
那當然台幣回來
大家第一個想到就是
外資開始歸對了好 這張表是不是有點複雜這張表仔細看你會發現到關鍵來了之前外資都還是一直賣一直賣
賣到這個月翻手買超之後
突然大家算一算
到目前為止
8月還沒有結束
下禮拜一還有開盤
已經買了3707億
這個數字已經是外資史上
單月買超台股的新高
之前最多也才差不多2400億
那關鍵來了
再配合著台幣現在這地方
開始出現轉維生值
轉維生值 轉維生值之後
同樣的現在
如果看到台幣由邊轉升
外資也開始翻多大買
過去的經驗你會發現到
有一次在2022年的11月
那時候也是外資本來一路的賣
開始轉買了
買了1867億
11月份單月
台幣也開始轉升了
結果台股
那一個月當然是收紅
但是你發現
才剛剛開始
後面從12629
漲到17463
漲了多久
漲了8個月
也就是還有7個月的漲勢
漲幅總共是達到38%的幅度
那再來到了過了一年之後
2023年的11月
外資又開始本來是調節到
翻多買了2400億回來
那台幣也開始升值
那一個月收紅之後
後面又漲了7個月
總共漲了8個月之後
漲到24416
這一次漲幅達到51%
再來最近一次就是在去年5月份
本來因為川普的關稅
外資也開始大賣
但是5月份開始翻多了
台幣也開始轉升了
台股那個月開始逆轉勝
從17306
川普殺到這地方
17306低點之後
翻紅上來
後面不要說漲到48000
漲了這地方漲到35000
就已經漲10個月的時間
漲了105%上來
所以我们会看到
当台币右边转升
而且外资也开始翻多大买之后
根据过去三次的经验
后面还启动8到10个月的行情
涨幅38到105%大多头
好像蛮值得期待
所以会不会这次
经过7月股灾的洗礼
融资大断头清掉了一批筹码之后
现在反而是另外一次的
大多头的开始
如果说外资的买盘现在归队
我觉得倒是值得期待
當然如果說比照過去經驗
不要講說105%比較誇張
38%的話大概這地方就有機會漲到大概5萬4千多上去倒是可以來做期待的好 而且發現外資雖然有買可是其實買一買它也是會變賣嘛但不太影響後續的走勢
好像只要幫忙點火就好了
對 就是推動公市的那一把手
開始推出去之後
股市就這樣
8到10個月的漲幅
你怎麼會想到這張圖的
可能觀眾想截圖了
突然發現這是藏寶圖
仔細研究就會發現
台股有很多奧妙的規律
會不斷的循環
只是我們怎麼去看到它而已
好 那當然我們接下來就觀察
那既然外資開始回來了
到底買了哪些股票呢
那這一張表我們先講
怎麼去挑出來
除了說是觀察到外資買超過
1萬張股票
但是也是看一下基本面
所以先統計前7月的營收年增率
有超過35%
那為什麼是35%的數字
是因為上市公司
整體的營收年增率
就是34.3%
換句話說它是超過平均值
在前段班的
那再來呢
不只是前七月
七月份的營收年增率
還比前七月總共加起來的累計年增
來得高
代表說進入到下半年
成長的速度
還有在繼續增速之中
所以這樣的條件挑出來
目前看到
當然買最多發現到在哪裡
在記憶體的股票
南亞科利基電 華邦電
還有後面有金豪科
裡面沒有列出來
還包括微缸 浴窗
其實外資這個月主要重點
幾乎都是在買記憶體為主
這個光是南亞科利基店
跟這個滑榜店
都是買超過10萬張以上
但這也可以理解
因為這個地方
這兩天也看到
這個地方基邦科技告訴大家
目前雲端服務平台
明年的資本支出
很有可能七成會被記憶體給吃走
回答也這麼講
對啊 好像記憶體變成標準配備
外資開始大幅度的回補
這個部分當然未來
我覺得還是可以持續的關注下去
那另外還包括像下游的部分
鷹葉達 神達 鴻海 技嘉華碩
這個部分也都有買超
當然如果說投資朋友說
到底怎麼去選
那當然如果選不出來
最簡單 台積電
那為什麼台積電
台積電符合
對啊 台積電其實這個符合
外資算不起來沒有買很多
超過1萬張而已
但是你會去看到
當輝達告訴大家
明年營收還會繼續成長70%的時候
最大收惠者是誰
當然就是台積電嘛
根據這台積電
這個第二季財報跟大家說
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕